so the baseline is we've had this
rhetorical escalation between Donald
Trump and Kim jong-un and their
respective associates Trump's threats of
fire and fury like we've never seen
before and I want to put sort of the
megalomania aside for a moment and
consider what it is that Kim jong-un and
others in North Korean leadership
actually want right if they had to say
as to what they are trying to get out of
this situation or of these escalated
threats that they involve themselves in
what is it that they want to often sort
of presumed whenever North Korea really
needs aid they start missile testing and
they make some threats and then they
agree to calm down those threats in
exchange for aid and this to me is way
more complex than that does kim
jeong-hoon really want to fight a war
does he think he could win is he trying
to get North Korea more recognition on
the national stage is it more about his
anger at the u.s. trying to intervene in
its nuclear research and realistically
it's some combination of all of these
factors and more right I mean there's
every indication that Kim jong-un does
want to be taken seriously on the world
stage there's every indication that he
would imagine hey if he has nuclear
weapons in a form where they pose a real
threat to the US and its allies then the
US and its allies won't be able to
ignore North Korea any longer in terms
of taking it seriously on the national
stage and the reality is the history of
American foreign policy probably also
makes Kim jong-un want more
sophisticated nuclear weapons we've
shown in the United States through our
foreign policy that we will topple
dictators we don't like if the
circumstances are right look at Gaddafi
in Libya who agreed not to pursue
nuclear weapons research and we still
took him out so if you're Kim jong-un
and you're at all rational and we don't
know if he is you're probably thinking
I'd better get these weapons so that
they don't take me out maybe having the
nuclear weapons not to use but as a
deterrent would make it so that the u.s.
might leave me alone and consider that
the u.s. by and large accepts the human
rights abuses of China
I mean diplomatically we issue
complaints China has new
and by and large there's no chance that
we're considering any type of
intervention to stop China's massive
human rights abuses not to mention we
also depend on cheap foreign cheap
Chinese labour and products to maintain
our American Way of life on the other
hand look at Ukraine Ukraine
legitimately had nuclear weapons after
the fall of the Soviet Union they gave
them up as part of the Budapest
memorandum on security assurances and we
know how Ukraine has fared since compare
that to Russia which has not given up
their nukes so in the background there's
that and then we also have to talk about
this desire from kim jonghwan for a
unified Korea when you go to North Korea
and you take any of these sort of
chaperoned state sanctioned tours they
give you all the propaganda about how
any day now there's going to be
reunification North and South Korea are
going to reunify and be one Korea being
a nuclear power maybe Kim jong-un thinks
well I'd be ever better be able to
coerce South Korea into reunification I
mean it's completely delusional right
South Korea has the raw materials and
equipment to produce a nuclear weapon
they don't have one but as nutty as Kim
jong-un might be he probably realizes
that you're not going to get
reunification merely by having nuclear
weapons you're going to have to go to
war with South Korea a war they very
what well may lose maybe he thinks I
don't know having some nukes could shift
the balance on reunification when you
think about the North Korean people
there's you know a certain amount of
naivete there because obviously they've
been brainwashed and isolated from the
rest of the world and you have to wonder
how much of that extends to Kim jong-un
himself now obviously he's you know more
well-traveled more enlightened than the
general population there but he's also
been surrounded by yes-man his whole
life and he's also you know was born
with a silver spoon so how much of that
nayeth naivete really extends to him I
don't know and that's the question it's
like we know that we have Trump and Kim
jong-un as total megalomaniacs
we know Trump's got plenty of yes people
around him I think in North Korea you're
right that is yes men specifically I
genuinely don't know and so that's what
I'm trying to balance in thinking about
what can
once out of this and you know it's
probably reasonable to think that if Kim
jong-un had nukes in the form that he's
researching them that maybe it would
deter outside intervention and then the
other thing is North Korea spends 25
percent of its GDP on the military that
that's huge it could stand to reason
that Kim jong-un thinks hey if we could
get these nuclear weapons we could not
spend as much on the military and maybe
moved some of that money into other
areas
I really don't know whether those
dollars would be spent on something that
would benefit the average North Korean
I'm skeptical of that but certainly it
might make some money available to
something else in North Korea maybe they
wouldn't have to have screenshots of
Google on their computer screens they
could actually access google.com that's
a reference to a documentary about North
Korea but I think that this is all the
many of the factors that are playing
into what's going on with North Korea
some of them are completely rational and
some of them are completely redo gional
like potentially this goal of
reunification with South Korea I don't
know but what we do know Pat is that the
escalation we've seen from Donald Trump
is like nothing we've seen with any
recent American president and when you
have a desperate president and one that
is basically a 71 year old manchild that
goes on Twitter to brag about nuclear
weapons which we'll talk about later
he's not the guy I want to count on to
be the sane sober and rational one
because he's not proven himself to be
that you have to wonder if this is a
distraction for him from the failures of
his presidency yeah but the thing is
that could completely backfire because
if Republicans and Congress witnessed
the escalation of tensions with the u.s.
and North Korea under his watch they may
find the Russia story as an emphasis for
getting him out of office it that's
interesting it could backfire there are
a number of ways in which this could
backfire and of course we are already
talking about well what kind of
intervention might we see would that
require an authorization to use military
force and the one issued I don't know
how many years ago ago to fight al Qaeda
is not going to cut it if you're looking
for military action in North Korea so
all relevant question legal questions to
your political questions pragmatic
questions about the mental state of both
our
their leader that's what we're dealing
with right now and you can send me your
thoughts about this on Twitter I'm on
Twitter at D Pakman and the show is on
Twitter at David Pakman show today's
episode made possible by tag adapt the
hosting specialist taga deb offers a
range of flexible hosting packages
including dedicated VPS and cloud server
options they also do custom server
solutions and colocation services taga
dab has a really user-friendly interface
and excellent customer support team
their expert hosting specialists also
are their friendly support team and they
give customers full access to their
knowledge and service with over 70% of
taga DAB's business coming from repeat
orders and recommendations and a
Trustpilot review rating of nine point
seven out of ten you know that taga dab
takes their customer service very very
seriously
with a growing number of people
interested in moving their businesses
and projects to the cloud tag Adad is
offering you as a david pakman show
viewer or listener a twenty british
pound free credits about twenty four US
dollars to all new customers signing up
to give you a chance to try their
services to take advantage of it go to
signup tag adapt calm /td PS for more
information on their cloud VPS and
dedicated server features once again
sign up tag adapt calm slashed edps use
the discount code TDPS 20